le centre commercial espace saint
quentin un nouveau gestionnaire
altarea commerce a été choisi par le
groupe allianz pour s'occuper de ce site
une décision suite au rachat de la
participation de la mersey par le groupe
allemand de l'assurance et altaréa
commerce a déjà une vision pour l'espace
commercial de montigny le bretonneux
alors c'est un actif très intéressant
puisqu'il a effectivement beaucoup de
fondamentaux très intéressant il a un
bassin d'emploi très important 145 mille
emplois sur la zone sur seize mille
entreprises des universités écoles un
centre de loisirs et des activités
loisirs très importante avec un cinéma
avec effectivement un théâtre également
dans la danse dans la zone
l'espace saint quentin c 130 boutiques
sur soixante mille mètres carrés avec
près de 12 millions de visiteurs par an
une base sur laquelle altarea commerce
va s'appuyer pour compléter l'offre de
restauration de loisirs et de services à
la personne proposés sur la zone mais
pas seulement on a également eu un enjeu
de diversification de l'offre sur des
activités qui manque un peu au niveau du
site
je pense notamment à la décoration à
l'équipement de la maison à
l'ameublement objectif renforcer
l'attractivité de ce centre commercial
qui date de 1987 avec la possibilité de
voir arriver de nouvelles enseignes
beaucoup de discussions ou l'imaginé
sont encore en cours soit sur différents
sujets de commercialisation il ya des
travaux qui sont engagés et que nous
reprenons à la suite de l'ancien
gestionnaire
donc on s'appelle effectivement déjà à
cette reprise qui est très importante
pour nous est fondamental pour pour la
suite pour le groupe altarea commerce
l'espace saint quentin vient compléter
un portefeuille d'actifs il gère
actuellement 2000 beau sur 40 centres
commerciaux en france